why did I think at age 52 when nobody
knew the who the hell I was that I was
going to be able to launch a successful
career
you demand you're worth do you ever hold
that no what's the like need motivation
what the dope then we believe nation
what's up believe nation its Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and join today's lessons from a
woman who went from being a prosecutor
and a judge in the Family Court system
to at 54 years old starting a new career
in television and becoming the highest
paid TV personality she's Judge Judy and
here's my take on her top ten rules of
success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what you love if you're not doing
something that you love to do find
something that you love to do because it
will make your whole life
different many people as I did at the
beginning got stuck with a job that I
really didn't like I would never have
stayed with that job or if I had to
financially I would have stayed with
that job and been an unhappy mediocre
lawyer in in a world where I could never
have had the confidence of doing a great
job so for you for your children boys
and girls find something that you're
naturally good at to figure out how to
make a living at it
nurture those if those of you who run
businesses who have women in their
businesses you have to realize that
they're doing a whole lot of stuff that
doesn't mean you have to cut them a
whole bunch of slack it means you're
supposed to demand excellence that's
what got you to run your own business
but make sure you're doing something
that you love to do and if you can't do
it as a vocation for whatever reason do
it as an advocation something that gives
you pure satisfaction is something that
gives you confidence if you can't do it
every day from 9:00 to 5:00 learn the
tango do something spectacular for your
soul I find that I'm having the time of
my life at 74 I just watched an HBO
documentary that was made by Carl Reiner
who was I think 97 and wonderful
comedian for those of you who don't know
who called Reiner is he he's Rob Reiner
'he's father and for those of you who
don't know Rob Reiner is it oh my god I
can't believe you don't know Rob Reiner
but his documentary is called if you're
not in the obit eat breakfast and it
really said every stage in life can be
an adventure you don't have to be
defined if you didn't make it in your
20s you can make it in your 30s and if
you didn't make it in your 30s you could
make it in your 40s and if you didn't
make it near 40s you could make it in
your 50s and just remember Grandma Moses
you know who that is
oh please tell me you remember Grandma
Moses she was a painter and she didn't
start painting until I think in her 80s
and one of the most prolific painters
never too late never too late no come on
that's what it's all about
rule number two make yourself
indispensable I think that women can be
respected and liked at the same time
there's a new book that came out and I'm
not Hawking the book even though she's a
dear friend of mine the book is called
leading lady and it's a biography of
Sherry Lansing who was the first female
president of a major motion picture
movie studio she's probably the most
beloved woman in Hollywood who would
think nothing of cutting you off at the
knees in a negotiation but she did it in
a way with a she did it in a way that
you almost felt as if felt good when you
left the office if you pick up the book
pick up the book it really exemplifies
what I'm saying to you you demand you're
worth
you have to excel you never make a
threat that you're not prepared to back
up when I if I said to my company if I
don't get what's on this little card
that I want for the next three years I'm
leaving I couldn't do this myself
without you and they believe me I'm not
going to tell you whether I would have
done it or not
but they believe me because I could have
and I had that kind of confidence so you
can only have that kind of confidence if
you make yourself indispensable at your
job whatever your job is whether you're
someone's secretary or assistant or
dentist or hairdresser or my makeup
artist is invaluable to me that because
somebody else couldn't do my makeup but
she has a great spirit so when I come
into work she's she gets me going so
she's made herself irreplaceable so
whatever she asks we give her and that
gives you confidence so you can be liked
and respected but if I had to choose
between being liked and being respected
I would choose being respected rule
number three don't hold back I get
letters thousands a year from people who
say you know you say things that we
think and that's why we watch you
because we can't say it at work because
it's not may not be politically correct
we can't say what you're saying to
someone because we have a fear that we
may lose our job or offend somebody we
will be called into human resources
because you said something wrong for
somebody all of a sudden the entire
monolith of business is down on you
because you move somebody's chair from
the right side to the left side you know
and they no longer near a window so
we've created an atmosphere where even
adults as adults
we're bullied and accept it and keep
quiet in order to be accepted that
people do that here and how we would you
know they may have opinions that are
inconsistent with that of the general
Hollywood flow and they know that if
they discuss their political views or
social views they won't work
do you ever hold back know what for what
for it's it served me well I think that
if you tell the truth you don't have to
have a good memory you can ask me the
same question that you asked me 15 years
ago I'll give you the same answer today
rule number four give
a shot and you worked as a lawyer and a
judge 25 years on the bench even before
you broke in a TV which you did at the
age of 52 right were there any times
that you said to yourself and this is
just too big of a risk I did I said it
right at the beginning because as most
of you know or even tangentially
involved with the entertainment industry
99% of the things that television
produces that all these really smart
people produce fail they spend a lot of
money they invest tens of millions of
dollars to launch a program and it goes
south so why did I think at age 52 when
nobody knew though who the hell I was
that I was going to be able to launch a
successful career at my age well you got
to be in it to win it it's like the
lottery says you know if you don't buy a
ticket you can't get that gold ring and
I said I have had a great career I
really loved the family for it I wasn't
bored with it but a little getting a
little tired of all the failure despite
my best effort and I thought this might
be an adventure you know but you had a
pension and your head your health
coverage and you still had those license
plates that were helpful but I gave it a
shot yeah and you gave it your all I
gave it a shot and the truth is the
people originally that produced my
program if I would have listened to them
it would have been a failure that's true
I can say that not because they can't do
anything to me rule number five have a
sense of humor if you're going to
deliver my kind of justice which is
always thoughtful always I always try to
get the relevant facts figure out what
what's really motivating the players in
this little drama but if you're going to
do that my style you have to have a
little bit of a sense of humor you have
to be notice what I did today
I was a little self-deprecating there
aren't very many women who was 74 who
said in the least in Hollywood who say
I'm 74 I'm old I'm not as old as
Methuselah but I'm oh that's
self-deprecating and a little bit of
sense of humor
delivered a message so it's a
combination of that that makes the
entertainment now I'm not an actress and
I don't have a script
so either you my father gave me a sense
of comedic timing because he was a
dentist and he had his he had his hands
in people's mouths so that they couldn't
talk and he loved to tell stories and I
would listen to him regale people with
stories and I realized what comedic
timing was when when to get in when to
get out and went not to get back in you
know you get in you get out and that's
it you don't get in and then you get a
laugh and then you go back in and I say
oh no there's not something one and the
self-deprecating part is people don't
want to think that you're smart and rich
and good-looking and have nice kids and
people don't want to hear all that they
want to hear that there's something
wrong that you're a little bit miserable
it's human nature it's human nature so
I'll say you know what if I had my way
I'd be 5 foot 8 and would have been a
runway model but God made me 5 foot 1
and you know a little short-legged to
the ground so you have to be able you
have to be able to give people something
say you know what she's a regular person
rule number six make a good first
impression the best advice I ever got
was you only have one chance to make a
first impression
I don't remember who gave me the advice
but I've been certainly dishing out that
piece of advice for the last 30 years
it's important because you do only have
one chance to make a first impression if
that first impression is a crummy one
you're clawing your way out for a very
long time so at every commencement
speech that I give I say to the
graduates if you take nothing else away
from this commencement other than your
diploma you only have one chance to make
a first impression rule number seven
have confidence I remember doing a photo
shoot my first year right before we
launched and they took a studio down
here to something called the Polaroid
studio I don't know if it still exists
these big Polaroid shots that they take
this size to put up budget on billboards
and stuff and the person the marketing
people were in Los Angeles and this
marketing guy sent his son who was about
26 or 27 dressed the part you know who
looked perfect and he was sitting there
and going something like this trying to
do something and then he said to me no I
don't think you should wear that I think
should with this color and I think you
should move and I said to him you know I
have food in my refrigerator older than
you are and I've managed to get by
knowing what my good side is people are
really I mean I'm not a glam person so
people are really interested in the
glamorous side the unglamorous side
they're just happy they get me vertical
if they get me vertical they should be
advocate so what you get at age 52
coming in even to a new business is if
you've had a good career you come in
with confidence and that's what it's all
about that's what business is all about
confidence you you know the song says
you can be a hero or a zero
the difference is confidence and if you
have created a portfolio for yourself
even in your own head that you are
really special and you know your
business and nobody knows whatever part
of that business that you do better than
you do that gives you confidence I knew
nobody knew more than I did about Family
Court and about judging a lot of people
I mean I only guess one or two answers
on Jeopardy so you have some idea of my
academic credentials but nobody knew how
to be a tactician in the court better
than I did rule number eight learned
from competitors you don't want to live
in a world where there's only one voice
you want to be able to say you know what
I know that this newspaper its editorial
page leans this way and I know that this
newspapers editorial page leans the
other way am i more comfortable reading
the editorial page that justifies
bolsters and enforces the way I feel
yeah of course I say that editorial page
is smart but a really smart person will
say now I'm gonna take a look at what at
what the competition has to say because
that makes you smart you see because
sometimes you can take away from the
competition
I mean the competition the competitions
in business like it's not as if there's
only one reader if the competition we're
speaking you know we're speaking in soft
terms right now it isn't that when
there's not only one person reading that
newspaper that newspapers is supported
by enough people so that it would seem
to me if you're reading one editorial
page you want to look at the other and
say you know what there were reason that
people are reading that editorial page
maybe there's something there that I'm
missing so you want both sides and if
you don't have reasoned debate then
you're a one sided fool rule number nine
get good at something you seem to be and
thank goodness because you have a show
20 years running because of these people
making the same mistakes over and over
and over again but I mean don't it is
frustrating when you see women being
taken advantage of because you would
think that because your show is very
popular it would kind of stop people
would women wouldn't be so desperate and
wouldn't let those clubs as you call
them into their lives and start giving
them all the stuff the only way it won't
happen is if you equip yourself to be
financially independent is it because
once a woman gives up financial
independence to a mate it's over yeah
because you're there's not an equality
anymore and I know I'm gonna get a lot
of mail I don't care I don't read
negative mail don't send me negative
mail what I'm telling you is you don't
necessarily have to use use your craft
use your career but you have to be
prepared because if you're not prepared
then you're stuck and more women have to
accept lifestyles that are unpleasant
because they are financially stuck so
with your smart you teach your
daughter's teach you granddaughters
everybody has to have something that
they're good at where they can earn a
living and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun don't ask me how I'm doing where's
my money
their money I do not owe horse anything
oh please she ran out of my house and
slammed the door break in the window I
was extremely upset so I grabbed a rock
and tossed it gently at her car
I like 10,000,000 people to hear that
you've done something stupid that's my
joy in life
you know my father used to stay out of
you used to say to me don't pee on my
leg and tell me it's raining
don't try to teach you to pick to sing
it doesn't work and it annoys them it
job ideas come from people who have done
praying so down
the expression beauty fades dumbest
forever edia playing done before it's
not an actress
they don't keep me here because I'm
gorgeous and 510 diameter squishing sir
don't feel like I eat him up for
breakfast you lie to me I'll wipe up the
floor with you worse than anybody else
who's ever tackled you you better tell
me the truth because I'm much smarter
than you are I love the truth yes you
don't tell me the truth you're gonna be
eating your shoes the truth
excuse me on your best day you are not
as smart as I am
on my worst day when I'm sleeping yes I
have stupid right here
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Judge Judy on how to have a back-up
plan that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions tying the
move from just watching a video to a
queue taking some kind of action in your
life in your business so answer these
three questions number one what can you
learn from your biggest competitor
number two what are you holding back on
and how will you release it this week
and number three what can you do to be
more indispensable for your clients
why start your own
action company
[Music]
actually somebody said to me you know
Cydia should really be funding a
production company for you I said really
so it was part of that one two three
three the third thing was you've got to
fund this production company for me and
you can get a first look at whatever I
produce so the first thing that we
produce is this lovely three-judge
program called hot bench which is now
going into its fourth season which by
the way with your original idea for your
show right yes the name for it was the
original idea and that's funny also the
mavens who knew not who knew know
everything they said what kind of a name
for that is the program just listen to
this thinking okay hot bench what kind
of a ridiculous name is that is it hot
[ __ ] is it hot bet I'm telling you
that's what they came back to me with so
I said fine you don't want to call it
hot bench call that Judge Judy they said
of Judge Judy we can live with now if
they had called my program hot bench
they could have replaced me when I gave
them this little envelope and said these
are the three things that I want because
yes right right
always always trying to outsmart so
fortunately for me we called it Judge
Judy and hot bench which is a novel
little idea but for those of you who
haven't seen it it's three judges who do
pretty much the same thing that I do but
then the public gets to see them watch
deliberations it's actually a good idea
for people whose faces in front of the
camera and I'm 74 and you know there'll
be a time when even all the lights in
the Empire State Building won't be able
to illuminate this face so within remain
on television and you know unless you
put a flashlight between your legs and
walk around with it so you have to have
something else to do you have to if you
want to stay engaged finds find a third
career find something else and I thought
that this might be a good way for me to
ensure that I
always had something to do ways your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that means that people have
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
if you want to learn from other
successful women entrepreneurs I highly
recommend my top 50 rules for women
entrepreneurs video the link is right
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there
curiosity really is I think at the basis
for all the kinds of things that I like
to try